while the focal point of every anime and
the most loved character in the show is
the protagonist the antagonists are
those that often make or break the story
in order for us to get involved with the
story there needs to be a challenge and
a threat and usually these challenges
come in the form of antagonist groups
sometimes these groups come and go in
one arc and sometimes they're a looming
threat like a storm in a distance that
we know the main character is gonna have
to face one day ladies and gentlemen
welcome to watch my mean Vinny tube
here's a list of the top antagonist
groups in anime starting off the list at
number 10 from one piece it's the big
mom pirates this group's one of the four
pirate crews that rule the open waters
of the new world founded and led by the
young Co Charlotte Lynn Lynn aka big mom
big mom pirate uses hull cake Island as
their base of operations almost all of
Big Momma's pirates are big moms sons
and daughters considering how many
children she has we're not really sure
where the big mom's fat or she's just
continuously pregnant she has 85
children who she uses as pawns often
engaging in political marriages for
growing her power and achieving her goal
of becoming the Pirate King big mom
Pyrrha acts less like a pirate crew and
more like a small country with ministers
and mayors some of the strongest big mom
pirates are the sweet commanders cracker
smoothie category daifuku oven and many
other notable fighters tactician Zhang
cooks
next on the list at nine it's our Giri
from Tokyo ghoul our Giri is a terrorist
organization founded by Etta yoshimora
it's believed to be governed by the
mysterious one-eyed King a figure
surrounded by speculation and seen and
unknown to most except for a few of the
our Giri members Etta often acts behind
the scenes but Tatara a direct
subordinate of the King has served as
the operational leader the algorri
are united with the goal of making
ghouls the dominant species
Etta has stated that the organization
has thousands of girls in their ranks
the majority being berated or below the
upper chain of command consists of many
S rank ghouls or higher like Misa I Otto
Tatara and na ki skewer course of like a
hickey kono sekai Yoko
[Music]
at number eight we have thi from Gintama
the key eight I was primarily made of
young men who wanted to participate in
the war after the samurai lost the war
many of the quixote members were
captured and executed in a post-war
purge by the bakufu this was done in an
attempt to eliminate threats and secure
their rule but in doing so they
motivated the key a tide to become more
extreme and dedicated to their cause of
overthrowing bakufu the leader and
founder of quiete is tak asougi's
schinsky a wanted fugitive rebel and
fierce samurai his fight against kintoki
is surely one of the best fights you'll
see in Shonen anime
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
Yoda onto number seven is the Ten
Commandments from the seven deadly sins
it's interesting how in this show the
good guys are the seven deadly sins and
the bad guys are the ten holy
Commandments this group is an elite
group of the ten strongest warriors
amongst the demon clan handpicked by the
demon king himself he created the Ten
Commandments to help him rule over the
demon realm he split his power to share
with his subjects making sure his
position isn't in jeopardy by giving all
of the power to a single individual but
instead dividing it amongst ten
fragments each member possesses a unique
power gifted to them by the demon king
called a commandment which casts a curse
on someone that breaks a rule of their
commandment such as Galan's truth
ability which turns anyone who lies into
stone
next on the list at number six is the
league of villains from my hero academia
founded by all mites arch-nemesis all
for one the league of villains is the
largest criminal organization we know in
the my hero academia world today it's
led by Tamora shigaraki and its goal is
to top off hero society by destroying
the symbol of peace all might while
tomorrow acts as an impulsive child who
wants to destroy for the sake of
destroying his right-hand man Kuro Giri
who has a calm and rational demeanour is
a perfect counterbalance a major asset
to their power is the artificial no
Moo's that awful one has created and
filled with quirks exactly how many
Nowruz they have is unknown but the fact
that a gnome who can stand their ground
against the most powerful hero or might
is the hint of the power that the League
of villains have got to Punga then I
guess you get to stop what he was
totally sunomono
mages say finished Amano at number 5 we
have jus pon katana
from rurouni kenshin shishio was a
former assassin who served the
government but after the government
attempted to assassinate him
shishio would go into hiding slowly
amassing power and forming his own
revolutionary militia to topple the
government as the head of the militia he
assembled a group of elite warriors the
Japan katana translating into 10 swords
the Warriors in the ranks of this group
are considered some of the most powerful
warriors in all of Japan although their
ranks are distorted and their fighting
styles differ they're all glued together
with their resentment for the Meiji
government and their admiration for a
shishio
[Music]
moving on to number four from Full Metal
Alchemist we have homunculus her monkey
light in the FMA world are regarded as a
sort of a myth the concept is known to
every Alchemist but no one's ever
managed to come close to making one
there are seven homunculus each named
after the original sin and somewhere on
them within them exists a philosopher's
stone that would allow them to transmute
seemingly without obeying the basic law
of alchemy to obtain something of equal
value has to be given each of the
homunculi are beings of unique immense
power in each with a personality built
around the sin they embody killing any
of them is a very hard task that
requires an insane amount of planning
and skill because the only way to kill
one of them
is to drain the Philosopher's Stone
within them of all of its power
[Music]
although soon condition yoga
at number three it's the Espada from
Bleach the Espada consists of the
top-ranking arrancars that rule all
other errand cars Aaron cars are a type
of hollow that gained strength similar
to that of a Shinigami by removing their
masks some removing the mask by
themselves and some through aizen's
experimentation the Espada's are equal
in power with that of the captains of
the gotei 13 all Espada's are ranked
according to their power there's a
tattoo on each of their bodies
representing their rank among the
Espada's for many the introduction of
the spiders in the subsequent art was
one of the highlights of the bleach
series and one of the best arcs next to
the soul society one mostly thanks to
the charisma of the Espada's themselves
and the epic battles they had with the
captains and ichigo since they're
ordered in rank already I'll just
mention that my favorite espadas our
fourth is spider
ulquiorra and ii aspired a grim job and
judging by the amount of cosplay I've
seen of just these two I'm guessing I'm
not the only one
circulate on you
see doctor
at number two it's a cat ski from Naruto
originally founded during the third
shinobi Wars by yahiko Nagato and Conan
three orphans of the second shinobi wars
knowing the pain the war brought them
they formed a cat ski with the goal of
bringing peace to their home country the
akatsuki collected the tailed beasts as
a path towards world peace by putting
everyone in a dreamlike state of
infinite tsukuyomi akatsuki's members
are all s-class ninjas some of the other
notable members are Kassim a dead ara
hidden
Sasori and Itachi Uchiha who was a
teenager slayed his entire Uchiha clan
which is an accomplishment but I
wouldn't put that on my resume
and finally at number one is the Phantom
troupe from Hunter hunter founded in the
meteor city the junkyard of the world
The Phantom trooper infamous in the
world of Hunter hunter for their
strength and ruthlessness the group is
made of formidable men users the leader
of the Phantom troupe is crow Lulu Silva
considered by many as one of the
strongest characters in Hunter hunter
his intellect fighting skill and a
complete lack of fear of death in
combination with his unique overpowered
ability that allows him to steal and use
other nin uses ability which he collects
in his book make him incredibly strong
we don't know how many he's stolen but
that book does seem pretty thick chrono
as well as other members put the troop
above themselves with the obvious
exception of his Sokka who puts his
fetish of young boys and I mean fighting
strong foes above everyone else The
Phantom Troop limits their love and
affection to within the group the rest
of the world sees another side of them
the cold-blooded criminal side they have
a complete disregard for life and morals
among their crimes the one we know most
intimately is the massacre of Carew
pikas clan the good clan for the sake of
the dark market value of this scarlet
eyes and if someone wants to join the
Phantom troop the procedure is very
simple just kill one of the existing
members
or it adds color or a creative
[Music]
so which are your favorite antagonist
groups let's talk about it down in the
comments section below
don't forget to hit that like button if
you liked this video and click that
subscribe button if you want to see more
content about anime thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]